Caroline's father hired some men to hunt
robai down and told them to get creative
with the punishment they finally tracked
him down in an area in Chicago Illinois
that would eventually become known as
Cabrini Green whatever the reason may be
Daniel robai was caught by the men and
they proceeded to saw off his right hand
and smear his body with honey stolen
from a local apiary people in town had
gathered around to watch the torture and
one kid takes a taste from the honeycomb
with his finger resulting in the coining
of robotti iconic nickname Candyman and
the whole crowd just starts chanting
Candyman over and over and that's when
the huge swarm bees located their stolen
honeycomb and furiously attacked the man
covered in their honey robai was stung
to death by the bees but it's said that
Caroline's pain was even greater than
his own he promises that his captors
will all be damned as her father
contemptuously holds her mirror up to
his face to show him the monstrosity
that he had become claiming Caroline
wouldn't even look at him now Daniel
robot's last words are Candyman as he
passes away